wenn die sendezeit gefüllt für heute
show sie können auch gerne etwas
rassistisches raushauen
[Musik]
auch über die politiker von heute und
wer wird dabei vergessen die politiker
von morgen wie oft wurde ist das schon
von einer freundin verlassen weil sie
herausgefunden hat dass der junge union
bist ja nie also hat es noch keine
freundin jedoch sind ja cool dass ihr
euch noch für politik interessiert und
nicht so was oberflächlich ist die coole
klamotten oder so ich glaube dass
politik und kleidung nicht unbedingt
immer korrelieren und das geht ja in
erster linie darum daher seine meinung
zu vertreten die meinung der jugend zu
vertreten
die kleine ist da nicht unbedingt die
ausdruck der politischen meinung
gleich die kleidung
ausrichter
nämlich ein terrorist ja ich stehe ja
mit einer vertreterin der griechischen
delegation position beim deutschlandtag
der jungen union
ich bin halt beim deutschlandtag um die
griechische deutsche zusammenarbeit zu
fördern
denn was wir in letzter zeit gesehen
haben ist die freundschaft zwischen
deutschland und griechenland
zerbricht was richtig ja gerade durch
die betze zum beispiel damals die
griechenland hitze
das war ein schock weil die griechen
dessen liebe leute wir hatten immer ohne
geld halt ne ja gestimmt so wie grün und
frau merkel 111 111
dagegen gehört das feature für andreas
scheuer
das ist hier ist wir sagen ja zum kreuz
im klassenzimmer und wir sind stolz auf
das glockengeläut unserer kirchen und
wir wollen den st martins umzug und den
weihnachtsmarkt
er feiere ich habe einen witz risiko hat
acht einen kleinen witz krise
vorbereitet ich habe wirklich lange
dafür gearbeitet
folgender witz was ist der unterschied
zwischen einem senegalesen und einem
doktortitel den doktortitel kriegt man
wieder weg top top besser geht's nicht
wenn die jetzt die sendezeit gefüllt für
heute show sie können auch gerne etwas
rassistisches raushauen ingo luge lego
city am start naja partie
die junge leute in den anderen sachen in
meinem alter reicht das schon vom sitze
hier weil ich immer zum deutschlandtag
der jungen union gehe waldmann abends
oft junge leute hören sind es so ich
dachte sie wären heute hier wegen den
ganzen jungen harten checks
möglich mein alter nicht mehr habe ich
anderes gehört ach ja vielleicht spricht
angela merkel schon aufgeregt ja kann
sein gesicht auch mal sagen mein gesicht
kannst du mal fünf dinge nennen die du
an merkel so richtig geil findet so
jetzt hab ich doch tatsächlich geschafft
hat 111 ii mit angela merkel machen
können und damit zurück ins studio und
wie häufig das jetzt alter der club
hatte er wieder alles wahnsinn
inhaltlich stark satire comedy gruppe
ich habe es noch drauf also ich würde
den kanal direkt abonnieren und auf
gefällt mir drücken wenn ich das nicht
schon getan hätte das war wirklich die
aktion
[Musik]